ground report com is a citizen news
reporting site that allows anyone to
publish their own articles videos and
photos to a global audience and earn a
revenue share based on their traffic all
of our work is vetted by our volunteer
editors and you can reach an audience of
millions some of our big scoops have
been the Beijing Olympics the Mumbai
terrorist attacks Taliban activity in
Pakistan and then even in our backyard
covering Obama's elections through
through the eyes and words of regular
Americans we have 5,000 contributors on
the ground who regularly submit stories
every day
building ground report space has been
completely deliberate it's not a typical
internet startup where you just want to
get as many people as possible we're
looking for a very sophisticated digital
reporter who is able to convey what's
going on from the ground level so we
want two things we want them to be savvy
enough to use the digital reporting
tools but we also want them to be on the
ground hyperlocal to report exactly on
what they're witnessing in their
immediate vicinity vicinity they don't
we don't want someone who's sitting at a
desk in New York writing about Pakistan
we want a pakistani lawyer who was
protesting the day before to be writing
about pakistan so I've been very
deliberate and doing outreach to
journalistic bloggers professional
journalists retired or students in
training and then also nonprofits a lot
of people who happen to be witnessing
some of the world's most urgent issues
and are there on the ground but lack the
proper platform to get the word out
the vetting process really happens at
the report level so anyone can sign up
and report immediately and submit
reports articles videos etc for
publication but it won't go live until
one of our editors takes a look at it so
anyone is allowed to do that that way we
don't miss the big scoops we open up the
doors in that way but we need that layer
of approval for it to really make sure
that it's up to our standards and to be
able to stand behind our brand name
we're happy to serve both of those
audiences I mean one of the biggest
things about hyper local news that is
covering covering issues and events at a
level that's even more granular than the
city level is that most of those topics
are really most interesting to the other
people who are living in that area so of
course a lot of ground reports coverage
that's that specific will be interested
interesting to people in those spaces
but on the other end we have people for
instance American audiences and just
audiences all over the world who want to
know what's really happening in the
world who recognized that the
international media is not serving its
goal to really inform the public and so
they're interested in these stories too
and they rely on ground report to sort
of aggregate and vet all of this
information that's coming in and give
you a real picture of okay here's what
people on the ground experiencing this
event feel about it here's what the real
story is
the only thing that we mean with the
original content policy is it means you
must have the rights to distribute
whatever content you post on ground
report so we're very happy to work with
people who are reposting from their blog
or from independent news sources in fact
they're some of our most valuable
partners what we don't allow is
copyright infringement or plagiarism
which actually is pretty rampant on a
lot of citizen journalism platforms and
that's because our biggest value at
Ground report we've made our name on
this is by having sophisticated original
content and original reporting and that
also helps us to pursue a syndication
model can't syndicate other people's
content it's also something that doesn't
really serve us in the end and it's not
the kind of contributors we're looking
for so we're happy to adhere to that
policy